hello my name is Phil Grafton and I'm
the monitoring officer for
stratford-on-avon district castle for
short I'll refer to the council as SDC
we are here to talk about the code of
conduct adopted by SDC for its own
councillors and we will also be covering
the model code that SDC is promoting for
adoption by town and parish councils
within the district whilst these two
codes differ slightly they are in
essence very similar and I will point
out the differences as we go along to
help me with this training session we
have two special guests who are an
integral part of the ethical standards
arrangements for all councillors in the
district hi my name is Sarah Goodall and
I am one of the two independent persons
who assists the monitoring officer in
dealing with code of conduct complaints
hello my name is Rosalind Bolton and I'm
one of the two parish representatives
who sit on the SDC audit and Standards
Committee which oversees standards of
conduct and conduct training across the
district the aim of this video is to
help councillors understand and put into
practice the requirements of their code
on a day to day basis as your code lies
at the heart of everything you do as a
councillor this applies whether or you
are an elected or co-opted member the
SDC website provides all the documents
you need including both codes of conduct
with general guidance and other
documents linked to the code every
effort has been made to ensure that
these documents are accessible and that
they are straightforward and easy to
read
this video is split into three parts
firstly we deal with the conduct rules
and you will be invited to look at some
case studies that draw out the
principles in the second part we take a
look at personal interests and lastly we
will take a brief look at the complaint
system at the end of the video we have
included some contact details for people
who can provide help and advice on your
code this video is designed to be
watched by a group of counselors
together with an officer who has some
experience of standards issues in this
way you are likely to get much more
insight from training it's also a good
idea to have a copy of your counsels
code and the case studies with you
before you start if you are a town or
parish counselor your clerk is the ideal
officer to be present as he or she is
also your first port of call for advice
on your code they will ask you to sign
an attendance sheet at the end of the
session and this is important because it
provides evidence that you have received
the training if you are a new counselor
the thought of having to follow a code
of conduct might feel strange at first
but the fact is that the Localism Act
2011 requires each in every relevant
local authority in England to have a
code of conduct to regulate the conduct
of its counselors and this includes
County Council's district councils and
town and parish councils in fact the
legal requirements I have a code of
conduct goes back much further than 2011
Parliament has long taken the view that
the public has a right to expect that
their representatives act in a way that
ensures that there is a set of standards
to regulate behavior and that their
personal interests do not play any part
or making decisions on behalf of the
public the way you conduct yourself as a
councillor is very important in
upholding your own reputation and
maintaining the confidence of the public
having count
and officers at all levels of local
government the Localism Act requires
each county district town and parish
council to dr. zone code based on the
Noland principles more of that later and
to include provisions for declaring
certain personal financial interests and
possibly other personal interests your
town or parish council has chosen to
adopt the SDC model code the Act
requires district councils in this case
SDC is monitoring officer to deal with
all complaints of breach of conduct for
all district Town and parish councillors
within the district regardless of the
code that has been adopted as part of
the complaints process district councils
are required to appoint at least one
independent person we have to at SDC to
give an impartial view in individual
complaints to the monitoring officer the
code adopted by SDC is slightly
different from the model that we promote
for town and parishes in the district
and that's because of the differences in
size function and resources but rest
assured that the purpose of your code is
to provide a clear and ambiguous
framework in which to conduct your
public life while keeping bureaucracy to
a minimum let's now take a closer look
at the two cones
these principles of public life were
introduced by Lord Nolan who was the
first chair of the parliamentary
Committee on standards in public life
and the principles have since become
referred to as the Nolan principles they
are widely embedded across public life
and form the basis for our two codes of
conduct the leadership principle asks
you to demonstrate these principles in
your own behavior and requires you to
challenge others whenever poor behavior
occurs do take time to reflect on each
of the principles the code only operates
when you're acting in your role as a
councillor so it does not apply to your
private life that said please remember
that in your public office your behavior
is in practice always potentially under
the spotlight and the reputation of your
colleagues and your council depends on
your good conduct at all times the
behavior also under Part A of the code
are largely self-explanatory but it's
worthwhile going through them briefly
one by one number one the principle is
respect for other people disrespect runs
from the modely offensive right up to
criminal conduct such as harassment an
increasing amount of the complaints I
receive are related to the use of social
media so for further information please
see the linked document on social media
also SDC councilors need to read our
protocol on member officer relationships
which explains the role of members and
officers the need for mutual respect and
the proper channels for resolving
conflicts that is outside of the public
domain this document does not apply to
town and parish councils
to use of the councillor position for
personal financial gain as we were
seeing part two of the video
failure to declare or take action to
avoid involvement in council business
that affects your own financial
interests can constitute a criminal
offense this one is serious three using
your counselor position to improperly
confer an advantage on yourself your
family or friends or conferring a
disadvantage on someone else is another
big topic and goes back to the Noland
principles of selflessness as opposed to
selfishness why did you want to become a
counselor for if you ever find yourself
under pressure from a person or
organization that offers you some
financial benefit to make a decision in
their favor or office your reward for
acting in a certain way please contact
me immediately bribery is a very serious
criminal offense five whatever the size
of your cancel it will have some
resources such as land property staff
who work for your counsel printers paper
etc all of these resources are funded by
taxpayers they are not there for your
personal use they are not there for your
use in your political role except in
some very limited circumstances for more
information for SDC counselors please
see the resources policy again this
document does not apply to town or
parish councils six generally all
council business must be conducted
openly and transparently this includes
public access to council meetings and
the agenda reports and minutes of
meetings
however by exception information can be
withheld from public access and in those
instances where you have a general duty
not to disclose confidential information
on the other hand you must not prevent
access to information where a person has
a legitimate right of access to the
information for example under Freedom of
Information legislation 7 the last
behavioral and the one that covers all
of the other six rule
is to remember that your conduct to the
counselor will have an effect on the way
that the public see your fellow
counselors and the counsel that you
represent trust and reputation takes
years to establish but it can be all
lost in an instant planning applications
are a danger zone for counselors
especially if you're a district
counselor on our planning committee to
help you please see the link document
good practice guide to planning that
brings us to the end of part 1 of the
video in part 2 we'll be looking at
personal interests how to spot them how
to declare them and the effects of
personal interest on your counselor role
in terms of participating in counsel
business and making decisions it's now
time for you to pause the video to allow
you to take a look at the case studies
on the behavior rules that your client
will circulate so you can discuss these
with your colleagues at the end of your
discretion your Clark will circulate the
model answers once you've finished the
exercises we'll move to part 2 personal
interests
on becoming a counselor you must declare
particular matters in a public register
this helps to give the public confidence
that your work is conducted
transparently and with integrity in
areas such as planning applications for
example there are three types of
personal interest the first to which you
must declare on the public register
as closeable pecuniary interests or
DPI's for short is a narrow band of
financial interests any one of which
could be directly affected by an item of
canceled business an example would be
you submit a planning application for
your own house it will be plainly wrong
to participate in any decision to be
made on that application failure to
declare a DPI or to give false or
misleading information is a criminal
offense there's a form to complete with
some notes and your clerk will supply
you with a copy appendix a of the code
sets out the list of categories of
interests that you must declare such as
employment sponsorship and ownership of
land and property common errors I see in
completed forms are failure to give
sufficient employment details that's box
Wan and failure to give details of legal
interest in land and property box 4 so
please pay attention to the notes on
this
in the same form you must also declare
any appointments to outside bodies in
certain situations and any gifts or
hospitality received where the estimated
value is 30 pounds or more see appendix
B these last two interests are known as
other registerable interests or ori x'
the separate guidance on gifts and
hospitality if you need to see it the
form must be completed and sent to the
monitoring officer within 28 days of
your election or appointment to office
failure to do so is a criminal offense
you must also give details for your
spouse or civil partner equivalent
although these details are shown as only
your interests on the public register
it's equally important to keep your
register of interests up to date this is
not just a protocol or good practice it
is a legal requirement again you must
notify the monitoring officer within 28
days of any change if you have any
questions when filling in the form
please seek further advice from your
clerk or from the monitoring officer
circumstances can change and what might
have been irrelevant to declare upon
your appointment may become relevant
over time with DPI's the law is very
clear if you attend a council meeting as
a nice one of business to be discussed
directly effects one or more of your
declared DPI's then you must not
participate which means that you must
not speak or vote at the meeting nor
attempt to influence the outcome if your
councils rules require it for example is
SDC then you must also leave the meeting
room while the item is discussed a
dispensation allowing you to speak
and/or vote is potentially available if
requested prior
the meeting but only if it meets the
strict legal grounds for district
councillors the request for a
dispensation is made to the monitoring
officer for town and parish councillors
the decision lies with your council
although it could be delegated to your
clerk for other registerable interests
you must not vote on the matter you are
allowed to speak on the matter but only
where the public are also allowed to
address the meeting for example you may
want to put forward the organisation's
case as to why it is applied for funding
but representatives from competing
organizations would also need to be able
to make their case a non registerable
interest needs to be declared where the
matter and discussion relates to or
effect rather directly effects an
interest of you a friend relative or
close associate or affects your interest
that you have declared in Appendix A all
that's a registerable body they have
declared in relation to appendix B of
the register an obvious example would be
of your daughter owned a company that
was bidding for a contract with your
council to undertake grass cutting
although this would not directly affect
you and it is not therefore a DPI it
clearly not be right for you to
participate in or influence the
council's decision so you would need to
declare an on register will interest
occasionally an item of business might
arise in your role as a councillor where
you have a personal interest but it does
not fall within Appendix A or B of the
code but you know that if you
participated in the decision your
personal interest would prevent you from
making a decision in the public interest
because of bias an example might be that
your daughter has made a planning
application on land that she owns you
would have an obvious bias there's a
two-step test to help you decide whether
you can participate in a matter step
one does the matter affect the interest
more than it affects the majority of
people in the ward or parish if the
answer is yes you then ask would a
reasonable member of the public knowing
all the facts believe that it would
affect your view the wider public
interest situations can arise where a
declaration of interest is not required
under the code but you still need to
make sure that you are not biased and
that you don't have a fixed position on
a decision to be made and retain a
closed mind known as a predetermination
right up to the point when you make a
decision otherwise the decision that's
at risk have been challenged possibly in
the courts in general the rule against
bias looks to the appearance or risk of
bias rather than bias in fact in order
to ensure that justice should not only
be done but should be seen to be done
obviously where bias or predetermination
arises you should not participate in the
decision an example of bias would occur
if you're involved in recruiting a new
employee to your council and you held a
personal grudge against one of the
applicants for some reason then clearly
you should not be helping to make the
appointment decision planning
applications also provide fertile ground
for predetermination so if you have very
strong views about an application and
you know that whatever happens your view
will not change when you have to make a
decision and this includes giving views
to the local planning authority then
that is predetermination the Localism
Act 2011 makes clear that you are not
taken to be predetermined when you make
a decision just because you have
previously done anything that directly
or indirectly indicated what view you
may take in relation to a matter and
that matter was relevant to the decision
in other words expressing a preliminary
view is simply a predisposition
so you are entitled to have a
predisposition one way or another as
long as you have not predetermined the
outcome you are able to express an
opinion providing that you come to the
relevant meeting with an open mind able
to take account of all the evidence and
make your decision on the day it's now
time once again to pause the video to
enable you and your colleagues to take a
look at some case studies on personal
interests with one of your officers for
town and parish council this is likely
to be your Clark at the end of your
discussion the model answers will be
circulated I'm pleased to say that the
number of complaints across the
Stratford district
well nothing to be complacent about are
not very frequent across the district
town and parish councils they're
currently number around 90 complaints
over the past six years so what happens
when a complaint is made first of all
there are helpful explanatory notes on
the SDC website for anyone considering
making a complaint and about the process
that will entail if they do if a
complaint is made then before anything
else it is recorded and considered
carefully by me as the monitoring
officer in consultation with the two
appointed independent persons to decide
whether a formal investigation is
required your code of conduct is at the
heart of everything you do as a
councilor whether you are talking to
constituents dealing with fellow
councillors attending council meetings
making decisions or spending money on
behalf of your community we have issued
a handy two-page summary of the code
requirements that your Clark or the DF
team will provide to you if you're a
town or parish councillor your clerk is
always the first port of call for advice
and guidance in addition the monitoring
officer is here to help we will want to
know whether you have contact to the
clerk first and if you have then he may
need to speak with the clerk before
confirming any advice the monitoring
officers details are as follows Phil
Grafton telephone number oh one seven
eight nine two six zero four hundred or
email address Phil dot Grafton at
Stratford
- DC dot gov dot uk' we hope you have
found this video useful and are looking
forward to your time as a councillor if
you do have any questions please speak
to your Clark or indeed don't hesitate
to get in touch with me personally thank
you for your time
you